captain Jonathan Parnell was a 31 year  veteran of the Detroit Police Department  Parnell worked the homicide squad he  lived this job and he loved every minute  of it  his friend lieutenant arc young  remembered our hearts are broken Detroit  Mayor Mike Duggan said the captain and  his three sons shared a love of football  when his oldest Jonathan jr. and Jeremy  both graduated Michigan State Parnell  returned to college himself to get his  bachelor's degree graduating summa [ __ ]  laude he pushed us and then we pushed  him says Jonathan junior who also became  a police officer at Wayne State  University that made his father  especially proud police work meant  everything to captain Jonathan Cornell  he was 50